un coup de fil à sa mère c'est à peu
près tout ce qu'elle peut faire
s'il faut qu'on s'autorise holmes au
dessus pendant 14 jours encore les noirs
from pour annie lemieux un drame
n'attend pas l'autre cette année son
père au québec est tombé gravement
malade infarctus chirurgie à coeur
ouvert
amputation d'une jambe faites moi je vis
tous ceux d'ici en faisant que le thème
un moment donné on jours en vo pour y
aller au point et à lyon au point y
aller mais non jamais annie et sa petite
famille se sentent prisonniers du
nouveau brunswick
toute l'année ils ont espéré un
assouplissement frontaliers mon père
était tout seul électeur navarrete tout
seul à la maison j'ai pas fait rage et
passeur donc elle était carrément tout
soeur annie n'était pas encore au bout
de ses peines
en octobre son père est mort avec tout
ce que le déplacement au québec implique
elle a dû se résigner à ne pas y aller
elle a assisté aux funérailles devant
son écran mais non tu es sur nos pc
c'est spécial c'est vraiment comme à
regarder un film mais sur les
funérailles de ton père tellement règles
sanitaires en atlantique sont parmi les
plus sévères au pays
si le bilan de lakovic 19 est enviable
la règle de l'auto isolement au retour
de de l'extérieur de la ville atlantique
a eu un impact énorme sur nos chiffres
qui sur la gestion à des éclosions ici
en à l'antique
il ne révèle pas les sacrifices des
familles qui ont des proches dans
d'autres provinces croit ni c'est pour
aller faire partie même que joueur et
que je veux a lieu au québec la crise et
pourra être le couple appuyer ma mère
al'approche défaite annie a raconté son
cauchemar dans une lettre adressée au
premier ministre et à la santé publique
du nouveau brunswick ce qu'elle vit
écrit-elle et inhumain dans ma part
l'année 2020 sera pas l'année colville
ça va être l'année du dessalement pas
elle s'accroche maintenant l'espoir de
recevoir sa mère chez elle pour éviter
que cette dernière nouvellement veuve
passent noël seul de l'autre côté de la
frontière
ici geneviève normes à radio canada
woodstock